Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan. Today, we are
taking a look at a real world application
using Fermion Spin.
Why am I saying real world?
Well, I wanted to build something that was
topical and that being some sort of AI
integration that shows you how to build real
applications with Fermion Spin. We're going to do
this with a multi component application.
We'll be using Spin's static file server to
serve HTML.
The simple HTML we're using today is just
a very simple form that will allow you
to submit a request to the back end
API. The second component on our Spin application
is a JavaScript back end component,
which will actually make an HTTP request
with authenticated secure credentials to the open API
service and give us a response which we
will display on the screen. Now this is
real world and that this would hopefully mimic
what you would want to do with Fermion
Spin and your real jobs, your day, your
real hobbies, your real side projects and so
forth.
Spin is great allowing you to componentize
multiple facets of your application. Here API and
front end, but that could be micro service
architectures where you have ten, twenty, 50 different
components all working together as one cohesive unit.
We're working with a third party service which
means that we have secure credentials we need
to inject in to our application.
And like most applications that have users and
growth, you're probably going to need a front
end. And Fairway on Spin allows us to
keep this very simple by just putting HTML
into a static file server. Of course, it
doesn't just have to be static HTML.
You could use Next.
Astro or any other static site generating capability
front end framework.
As long as this spits out a build
directory, you can serve it with Fermion Spin.
And in fact, in this video today, we're
going to take my crude HTML and deliver
it with Astro.
So let's dive right in. So let's set
the scene and see where we are right
now. Currently, we have a spin application which
has the two components I mentioned on the
introduction. The first component as our real app
OpenAI language guesser. That's right. We're gonna allow
the user to input any arbitrary language text.
We're gonna send that to OpenAI and ask
it to qualify it, to tell us which
language it thinks it is. We will then
return this to the user. We're building this
in JavaScript and we'll take a look at
the tool chain for doing that in just
a moment. As with all Spin applications and
if you haven't seen one before,
check out the rest of this course on
my YouTube channel. There's over five hours of
content to show you how to build Spin
applications in Rust,
Python,
dot net, JavaScript
and more. Now because we need to use
a secure secret and actually I shouldn't have
ever quoted that, this is a real secure
secret. This is a real API token for
my OpenAI
account. So we say that we expect some
piece of configuration and our component,
notably, we expect the OpenAI token. Now we're
going to render this from a variable
and we'll come back to that in just
a second. Because Spin allows us to have
multi component applications,
we have to set up a rip or
a rip prefix that tells it to send
all the requests from that to this component.
We're gonna keep our API simple and see
the anything that matches slash API will go
to the JavaScript component. Next, we're going to
use our build step. For our build step,
we're telling to run NPM run build.
If we pop open our package dot JSON,
we'll see here that we use a webpack
in production mode
and spend a JS to Wasm plugin to
compile our JavaScript application to a WebAssembly
Wasm binary.
As such, this is the same binary that
we provide as a component source.
Next, we have to tell the spin application
that we have one required variable or this
application will not work. Here, I'm just in
open a I underscore token is required.
Okay. Let's take a look at our last
component. This is the static file server that
will serve our assets.
Currently, a single HTML file. We use this
long line source here because Spin has the
ability to consume Wasm Spin modules anywhere on
the Internet. We're pulling this from a GitHub
release artifact on the spin fail server repository.
We can give this an ID, notably we
call this one front end. Novel,
not so much. Then we configure the files
that we want to serve and in this
case, we're going to serve the front end
directory, which has a single index dot HTML.
Here, we just take the text, submit,
and send it to the API endpoint.
Nothing fancy,
but we're going to change that in a
moment. Next, we can configure the fail server
to fall back to another path if required.
Here we're saying that the fallback path is
index dot HTML.
This just means that on our component which
has a root prefix of slash, meaning anything
slash except API
will go to our static file server component.
If that file doesn't exist, we just return
the index.
It just means that we can hit local
host port 2,000 with nothing and get the
correct page. So
does it work? Well, it does. On our
command line, we're currently running our spin build
dash dash up command, which will build this
and spin up our project. We can pop
off into our browser where I have a
split tab configured. On the top, we have
our spin and front end application. Well, at
least our front end application, which will talk
to our back end application.
And we have Google Translate. Here, I've asked
it to to
hello to Estonian,
which we can copy and paste. And if
we had determined language,
our application,
after speaking to OpenAI, tells us that this
is Estonian word meaning hello or hi. Let's
choose one more language. This time, we'll pick
Italian
where we'll copy ciao,
paste, and determine.
And it tells us Italian.
Perfect. So let's take a look at the
back end and then we'll look at upgrading
the front end. If we pop open Versus
Code, we'll have our index dot j s
for the back end service.
Here, we have an asynchronous function called handle
request
where we consume through the Spin SDK config
object our OpenAI token.
This is provided through Spin config. Spin config
just means any environment variable on a host
that starts with Spin underscore config underscore
the config key will be projected into the
spin runtime. If I jump to the command
line and run dart n hello, you'll see
that my ENVRC
has a spin underscore config underscore open a
I underscore token. The spend runtime collects this
and makes it available on the config object,
all because of the things that we've seen
earlier in the spend dot toml. Now because
currently our front end application is just using
a very simple form with a method post.
We're going to receive that as a URL
search param on
the body object. So we can consume the
request dot text, which means get the body
as text and store as query string.
We can then use URL search params to
parse that to get our form data. From
here, we're just using the standard fetch API
where we send a request to OpenAI.
Method post with the correct headers for authentication
and content
followed by a JSON string for our body.
Here, we provide to the model that we
want to use, the message which contains a
role and content.
For us, the role is user and the
content is just a prefix that says what
language is this?
Followed by end quotes, farm data get text.
You can set the temperature to adjust the
way that OpenAI handles the request.
This is not a video in OpenAI, so
I'm not going to go in that in
any further detail today. Next, we can await
the response and parse it as JSON, meaning
we can send a response with an HTTP
200 and our body where we encode data
choices,
first result message content. That might seem a
bit complicated. It's just because OpenAI
returns multiple
choices or options for you to select from.
We're always going to select the first. We're
always going to select the message and the
content. We're not worried about the role, the
temperature or anything else that OpenAI returns. And
we have to encode this because this is
WebAssembly
and we have to spit it back out
correctly for the consuming browser. And that's it.
So hopefully this gives you a taste of
something that you can build with Spin, with
multiple components, with third party services and secret
tokens. But let's improve our vanilla HTML.
Here, I'm going to do a p n
p m create astro
at latest. This is gonna guide us through
the astro website creation process.
From here, we get this a name for
our project and I'm going to call this
front end v two. I'm going to use
the blog template just so that you can
see all the astro stuff just works even
though we're pushing in our own piece of
HTML.
So let's just give that a moment. We'll
install the dependencies
and if you want, you can choose to
use JavaScript or TypeScript. So let's say yes
to TypeScript,
restrict to statin and no, we don't need
a GET repository. So let's pop in to
front end v two where we can run
a PMPM run build. This is gonna create
a dist directory
with all of our front end assets, HTML,
JavaScript, and so forth. So let's pop back
here and pop open our spin dot toml.
We can modify our source to be front
end v two dist,
which will serve our correct assets.
If we pop back over to the terminal,
we can run spin build
up.
Let's pop open our browser
and refresh the top. And now we have
our ASTRO website,
which is very zoomed in, but here we
go. So let's make a change to the
ASTRO homepage.
So let's open index.ASTRO.
From here, we can change hello astronaut to
be hello spin fans. You now do more
astro like stuff such as including style tags.
The reason you're probably wanting to use some
sort of front end framework is to make
your front end life easier.
So just let it do that. Here, we
can say color red and we'll add Rawkode
where the color is blue. We can now
come down to here and see that we
don't have an h two. So let's create
one.
This should be red.
And we'll also add
class equals Rawkode.
Two, that this template comes with a few
integrations line.
Now, if we're emphasizing here that we're just
working on Astral land doing Astral things. So
let's go back and we'll build our Astro
site one more time. This compiles it and
creates our static HTML inside the desk directory.
We can then relaunch our Spin application
and give that just a moment to become
healthy. Now if we pop back over here
and refresh,
we have spin fans, red and blue. This
is just to show you that when you
work with front end frameworks
and spin applications,
you don't need to compromise. You can take
advantage of React, Fail,
Astro, whatever you like. Build a workflow that
works for you and consume it with the
Spin Fail server. But of course now,
we wanna hook this back up to
our API.
So let's go back to Versus Code
and we'll go into our front end and
just copy
the form that we had before. And we're
just gonna replace our h two and drop
it straight in like so.
Now this should just work because it's just
a simple form that sends a post request
to the API endpoint.
But we do need to run build one
more time followed by spin
up.
And now we can come back.
We have refresh
and we have our form. We can select
a new language. Let's go with Thai. We
can copy,
paste,
and determine.
And this is the Thai language. Perfect.
And that's it for today's short tutorial. You
can write spin applications in your language of
choice. They get compelled to WebAssembly. They're easy
to run locally and you could deploy to
Fermion Cloud. You don't need to throw away
all your favorite front end frameworks or other
tools because they're quite easy to integrate web
the spin framework. By just modifying one or
two lines in the spin.toml,
you can grab your statically generated site,
serve it via WebAssembly module directly to your
customers. I hope this gives you some inspiration
for things you can try out with Fermion
Spin. So go do that and let me
know in the comments what you get up
to. Have a great day.